Hello Mike had so Mike is this person spouse had a grade 4 astrocytoma removed almost two years ago
Several months ago his brain scan started to change and they just scheduled him for surgery next week
Does he need to change or stop any supplements
prior to surgery?
So yes, so if you're doing going to do surgery, you don't want to take any supplements with
anti
Coagulators that are anti-coagulating type supplements. So anything really with
um
garlic in them
Anything with even omegas, I would say don't do what you're going to do through three
But the most important one to stay away from is is garlic
So garlic is going to be you know the one that's going to thin your blood the most and it's going to cause difficulty in clotting
And you don't want there to be any difficulty in clotting with the surgeons doing surgery or post-surgical
You want to make sure that you're clotting and you're
Orbit um you get fibridogen laid out and your other you're getting healing
So that's the biggest thing that you would do
um
Prior to surgery
So
Will any of his supplements interact with anything that he's given with surgery
Vitamin C is the only thing that he said he's going to be on
Well, I don't know that uh, so they're
The unknown is you know, they're you're going to be given you know
Some type of drug to knock you off for the surgery and literally there's just no known interactions with those types of drugs
And go idea of what they're going to use
Then there's no known interactions with that. So you're just safe to like two days
Maybe three days before the surgery just go off of everything and don't start
Any of the supplements back up and tell a few days later
We know that there's proper healing and blood clotting and you don't have any beliefs or anything like that that you can go back on stuff
Even at that if you were taking a garlic pill
Like a you know us you know, there might be garlic in like glutamate scavenger or something like that that you're taking
But not enough to be an issue multiple days after the surgery
But if I was two three four days out from the surgery, I still would go on a straight garlic pill
You don't want you still want to make sure that you're not going to end up with any beliefs
So safe wise, I would just go off
Two days before and just stay off of it for a few days afterwards